un plan de relance entachée par une
crise politique ce mardi 222,9 milliards
d'euros de fonds européens ont été
débloqués pour l'italie afin de faire
repartir une économie meurtri par
l'épidémie de coronavirus un des plus
grand investissement jamais engagée en
italie selon le ministre de l'économie
roberto gualtieri le conseil des
ministres lance le recovery plane le
plus grand plan d'investissements jamais
vu sur need ali grâce aux ressources de
européenne notre pays peut désormais
réellement changé elle c'était un
excellent travail à plus important que
toute controverse
il est maintenant temps de tenir un
débat au parlement et dans la société
l'italie a un rôle déterminant dans
cette première initiative de dette
commune européenne
et c'est sur fond de scission cours a
lieu ce test la coalition au pouvoir
dans le pays ne parvient pas à se mettre
d'accord sur l'utilisation des fonds
alloués
les avis divergent entre giuseppe kanté
premier ministre italien et son premier
rival matteo renzi patron d'italia viva
ce dernier reproche au chef de
l'exécutif des décisions qui desservent
le pays
il menaçait alors de faire exploser la
coalition
malgré tout 12 et piquante et a pris en
compte les exigences de matteo renzi en
acceptant de doubler les fonds alloués à
la santé et redresser la part des
investissements
l'ex-premier ministre tempéré de son
côté le conflit actuel
je ne veux pas bloquer quoi que ce soit
l'intérêt du pays passe avant tout mais
immédiatement après nous ferons ce que
nous devons faire une trêve en demi
teinte puisque une fois le plan de
relance adopté au parlement
la crise politique qui battra de plus
belle plusieurs options sont alors
possibles
une démission des deux ministres au
gouvernement d'italia vivent à un
remaniement qui induit de nouvelles
élections législatives ou encore la
nomination d'un nouveau premier ministre
l'italie vit une crise dont il est
difficile de prédire l'issue si giuseppe
kanté et matteo renzi ne mettent pas
leurs différends de côté les voix de la
majorité en appelle à la responsabilité
des deux hommes politiques dans un
contexte de crise sanitaire qui
n'épargne pas l'italie
plusieurs mois deuxième pays d'europe le
plus touché